hey guys what's going on there's not
that much going on in the Bitcoin Market
this week and so instead of having some
sort of market update I thought it'd be
even better to bring will Clemente
co-founder of reflexivity research on
for a very short conversation we're
going to talk Bitcoin stablecoin
centralized exchanges onshore offshore
and a few other things here's my
conversation with Will Clemente all
right guys bang bang well I thought a
great place for us to start this
conversation would be around the
aggregate trading volume in the crypto
markets is it going up is it going down
is it going sideways what's going on
yeah for sure so in the charts that you
can probably see on the screen are you
just looking at the aggregated crypto
trading volume so you look at all the
tokens across the entire crypto
landscape and look at the daily volume
that that's being traded across all
these tokens uh as you can see in the
chart uh crypto trading volume this
month is down from 23 billion dollars to
just 9 billion uh which is uh Standalone
a pretty substantial decline but when we
look at kind of the trailing two three
years it's actually the lowest that
crypto trading volume has been uh since
the end of 2020 and so what does this
represent it represents that a the
market it's kind of in this period of
apathy and what I like to describe as
kind of capitulation Through Time right
we kind of have capitulation through
price and then we kind of bore a lot of
Market participants out and shake them
out that way uh and also just reflects
the declining interest overall in the
kind of crypto ecosystem what about the
different exchanges are they all seeing
this decline or some of them gaining
market share or losing market share yeah
so when we like break down volume and
look at it across the different venues
uh binance remains kind of the 800 pound
Grill in the room by far they're
exchange dominance across all the
different venues and in cryptos still 56
it's come down about 15 from its peak uh
the back half of last year after the FTX
blow up but binance is still by far the
dominant exchange and then if we look at
the different exchanges some of these
are based in the United States some of
them are offshore what are we seeing
there in terms of are the narratives of
U.S companies moving offshore Traders
moving offshore is that actually true
yeah absolutely you know one of the
issues that we've seen for for crypto
throughout the year
um has been kind of the regulatory
uncertainty throughout the U.S you've
seen SEC and some other kind of like
government bodies taking a very harsh
stance it's probably the friendliest way
to put it towards the crypto space and
so with that there's a ton of regulatory
uncertainty for operators and crypto
including uh you know market makers as
well as you know crypto projects that
are looking to launch here in the states
when we look at crypto trading volume
broken down by as kaiko has labeled here
in the chart offshore and us-based uh we
can see that the vast majority of crypto
trading volume takes place offshore
about 86 percent therefore 14 takes
place here in the US and I find it
really hard to believe that this is
going to change if we don't see more
regulatory Clarity here in the U.S which
is actually kind of the opposite of what
uh at least if the SEC and other
government bodies are being truthful and
that they they want to you know kind of
have provision over the space what
they're doing now is is the you know by
looking at this data is doing the exact
opposite of what they're saying they're
trying to accomplish right
um You Know by saying that you know
we're going to not provide any certainty
or you know friendly regulation towards
uh crypto companies
it's forcing forcing them to go offshore
um therefore you know it's it's doing
the exact opposite giving them less
provision of of the entire space uh and
the same lines of if they were friendly
towards crypto companies encourage them
to come within U.S borders they would
actually have uh you know kind of more
oversight and more quote-unquote control
on a spectrum of control that they'd
like to have so you also looked at the
various trading Pairs and what we see
here is that we have USD usdc busd right
usdt Etc but there's a new TUSD that
seems to be gaining tons of market share
explain what is TUSD as a trading pair
and then why is it eating so much market
share from these other uh trading pairs
yeah for sure so in the chart here we're
just looking at all the different
trading Pairs and the percentage of
overall trading volume that they make up
um over the last like year and a half
the dominant pair has been busd uh the
reason for that is very simply because
binance launched a trading promotion
where they said anyone that trades
against the busd pair which is their
stable coin that they created with paxos
um they get they don't to pay any fees
on the exchange they removed that about
two months ago in the back half of March
but they kept the promotion going for
TUSD which is in some groundbreaking
stable coin the only reason that they're
kind of relative market share has gone
up of overall trading volume is simply
the fact that binance has kept that zero
fee trading promotion going for them
when you look on centralized exchanges
we can compare Fiat to stable coins and
it seems like stable coins still remain
the dominant uh kind of asset on those
exchanges yeah definitely we saw a
slight hiccup in that
um around some of the usdc stuff but
stablecoins definitely remain the
dominant uh trading pair and part of
that again is the fact that the offshore
exchanges Remain the the dominant uh
venue between you know offshore and U.S
base I think it's also worth noting that
when we look at liquidity
um this has just continued to decline
and also something to look at in
Confluence with the overall trading
volumes when we look at liquidity
defined by at least in the chart we have
here on the screen when we look at the
two percent bid ask depth so essentially
you're just looking at what's the amount
of Bitcoin in the order books that's
between the current trading price and
moving the price up two percent or
moving the price down two percent so in
other words you're looking at you know
how much liquidity is in the books
um and how much price impact are you
going to have as a large Market
participant looking to place a large buy
or sell order and so when liquidity
declines that means that there's a
higher
um susceptibility to large volatility
because larger players have a larger
price impact on the orders that they're
putting into the book and so this has
continued to decline uh since last year
especially had a sharp decline after the
kind of uh collapse of FTX and we've
actually seen that translate to some
tangible announcements so Jane Street
which is a very well known traditional
Market making firm announced that
they're pulling back from their crypto
operations entirely and jump who's also
a well-known market-making firm from
traditional Finance who has been pretty
active in in crypto I'd say them and
a16z are two of the you know largest uh
players or have been in the crypto space
um also announced that Jump's going to
be pulling back their at least U.S based
uh crypto Market making operations they
said that they're going to migrate that
to
um offshore and they'll continue kind of
operating in that way but again both of
those things are just tangible
reflections of uh a lot of the
regulatory uncertainty that we've seen
in the US and that that also has been
reflected uh in overall liquidity
measures both across BTC uh and ethereum
when we go and we look at stable coins
what's interesting to me is that tether
still makes up like 76 of all stablecoin
usage on these centralized exchanges we
just talked about all these trading
Pairs and different assets and different
dominance for those assets but tether
remains King in terms of just straight
stable coin usage on the platforms yeah
it's it's kind of funny uh I guess is
the right word to say you know with all
the concerns around the transparency
from tether uh in in the crypto
Community a lot of people like to call
the people that have been bashing tether
for the last 10 years the tether
truthers
um you know I haven't gone in and uh you
know kind of broken down uh some of
their attestations and things like that
in as much depth of other people
um but it is kind of funny to see a lot
of the concern that people have been
expressing around tether meanwhile uh
their market shares had an all-time high
and usdc who has kind of advertised as
this transparent alternative uh their
relative market share has been on like a
Perpetual decline for the last two three
months ever since they had a lot of
issues around the svb banking crisis
stuff
um so yeah now tether's uh dominance is
up to I believe 76 percent
um at least in terms of like the
aggregated stable coin supplies it's
somewhere around that for the for the
trading volume that they make up uh and
we also have seen that the number of
tether in that have been issued in
circulation is also about a very call
time high I think it's within like 100
million dollars or so of doing that the
last question I have for you is around
Sushi swap in uniswap V3 it looks like
sushi swap basically had 100 you know
market share of these two uh and then
all of a sudden out of nowhere uniswap's
V3 has absolutely dominated the market
what's going on yeah so in this chart um
we essentially just look at the relative
market dominance between Sushi and uni
only because those were the two uh dexes
that we were able to get on the chart
like on the Fly when we were creating
this it'd be much better if we had kind
of an aggregated view of all the major
dexes but the point I'm just trying to
illustrate here as a unit swap has been
the dominant decks by far but what I
think is even more interesting we don't
have a chart for this specifically when
you look at centralized exchange volume
relative to decentralized exchange
volume decentralized exchange volume has
continued to make higher lows and
actually has reached an all-time high
over the last few weeks and so what does
that indicate I think again it's a
reflection of that regulatory
uncertainty right because as you have
more of that in the U.S people are going
to move a offshore but also on chain and
so as you know you have a lot of these
dexes that continue to build out their
products you know increase liquidity
um you know kind of easier you know
interfaces to interact with these
protocols I think it's also logical to
expect that that Trend continues as well
so
um you know as things kind of currently
sit I think the trend of continued
Capital moving offshore and on chain
with the regulatory uncertainty here in
the US is likely to continue and so the
decentralized exchanges continue to hit
all-time highs and usage do you think
that'll continue yeah on a relative
basis to the centralized awesome I hope
you guys enjoyed today's conversation
with Will Clemente co-founder of
reflexivity research and we'll see you
guys next week